ADBLOCK BAN:
YouTube is stupid for blocking AdBlock.
Not just from some sort of information should
be free and screw big corporations mindset but
from a grounded fundamental perspective.
This might be confusing to hear. Wouldn’t
blocking AdBlock lead to more people viewing
ads and/or upgrading to YouTube premium? That
would lead to more revenue for YouTube,
not less right? Well, while that argument
may seem true at first glance, it doesn’t
hold up against scrutiny and here’s why.
EVERYONE USES IT:
First of all, let’s establish just how popular
ad block really is. As of 2021, 42.7% of internet
users worldwide use ad block. This number is
likely a good amount lower on YouTube because
people tend to watch YouTube on mobile devices and
TVs where AdBlock doesn’t work but the point still
stands, AdBlock is extraordinarily popular. And,
when you combine this with the scale of YouTube,
we’re talking about hundreds of millions
of people. YouTube literally has 2 billion
monthly active users, so even something that only
affects 10% of users adds up to 200 million people
much less 42.7%. So, safe to say, we’re talking
about a lot of people which opens up YouTube to
substantial reputational risk. You might be asking
why? After all, YouTube isn’t doing anything wrong
by forcing ads. It’s their platform and they’re
providing billions of people with value whether
that be educational value or entertainment value.
So, it’s only fair that YouTube expects to gain
some value in return whether that’s directly
through YouTube Premium or indirectly through ads.
That only makes sense, but the reality is that
what’s fair is mostly irrelevant. You see, people
often like to get mad at big corporations and say
that all these companies care about is maximizing
profit over everything else. And that’s completely
true, but here’s the thing, it’s the same way
with like 90% of people. The only thing that the
vast majority of people care about is what value
they get from a business. They don’t give a crap
about the business making some money. They might
have some sympathy towards a mom and pop shop or
local restaurant but with a mega corporation like
Google, that sympathy is non existent. In fact,
most people are happy when these companies lose
money or embarrass themselves. How do I know that?
Well, those are usually my most viewed videos. So,
with that being said, the average person simply
doesn’t care if AdBlock is losing Google money.
And this is extremely important to note because
it lays the foundation for how people will react
to an AdBlock ban. Hundreds of milllions of
people have been conditioned for over a decade
to watch YouTube for free without any ads. When
you change that, they’re naturally gonna get mad.
REPUTATIONAL RISK:
When hundreds of millions of users get mad, you
start seeing substantial backlash against the
company. But, this doesn’t manifest in the way
that you might expect. It’s not like people are
gonna throw fits on Twitter and make a scene. Wait
nevermind, people are already doing that but this
isn’t most people. Most people will never argue
that AdBlock is good or that YouTube is wrong
for banning AdBlock because well, they know that
it’s mostly fair. But, what people will do is hold
a grudge that they express in several different
ways. And the perfect example of this is Netflix.
You’ve probably noticed that over the past 12
to 18 months, people have suddenly started to
hate Netflix. If you read through YouTube comments
about Netflix, you’d be convinced that the company
is on the brink of collapse or something which is
absolutely not true. Yes, they lost subscribers
for a quarter or two, but they’re already gaining
subscribers once again. Also, even if they did
stagnate, over 200 million paying subscribers
is nothing to complain about. But then,
why are people so pessimistic about Netflix,
even rooting for its demise? Well, it really
just comes down to this. Netflix is increasing
prices, they’re implementing ads, they’re cracking
down on password sharing, and they’re losing
content to competitors. That’s the bottomline,
but most people will never admit this. Instead,
they’ll point their finger at some BS reasons some
of which may have even been advantages previously.
Take Netflix’s content catalog for example.
Nowadays, it’s popular to say that there’s a lot
of stuff on Netflix, but none of it is good. When
you were sharing passwords with 4 friends and
only paying $4 per month, having too much content
likely didn’t seem like a negative. In fact, I
bet most people viewed it as “Yo, this is awesome.
I’m never gonna watch most of this stuff, but the
fact that I can get all of this for $4 per month,
that’s insane.” But, when you have to pay full
price, the attitude suddenly switches to “Bro,
I’m paying $20 per month and they can’t even show
me something that I wanna watch. What is this.”
It’s the same Netflix in both scenarios. Even
the pricing is the same. The only difference
is password sharing but now it’s the platform
that’s sucks. The same sort of thing will happen
on YouTube. Most people will never blame YouTube
directly for blocking ad block but they’ll take
out their anger on every other shortcoming of the
platform like the algorithm. It’s no secret that
YouTube recommends some random stuff from time to
time. Normally, people take this pretty jokingly.
They might go onto this random videos and
comment “Yooo, the algorithm is drunk again”.
But, when they’re forced into buying
YouTube premium and the same thing happens,
the attitude shifts to, “Dude, Google is
a trillion dollar platform and they can’t
even figure out recommendations? This
is unacceptable.” People are naturally
really good at finding justifications for their
grudges. In fact, that’s probably why many of
you are watching this video right now. You want
justification for using AdBlock. Whether this
is fair or not is besides the point. That’s
simply basic human nature. And as a company,
it’s in YouTube’s best interest to be cognizant
of this bias and act accordingly. Otherwise,
it may not be long until they end up with a brand
favorability like Netflix at a staggering 11%.
PROHIBITION DOESN’T WORK:
Putting the whole branding aspect of blocking
adblock to the side, the reality of such bans
is that they don’t even work. The most classic
example of a ban not working is prohibition. Back
in the 1920s, the US decided that it would be a
great idea to ban alcohol, but this didn’t stop
people from drinking. It simply led to illegal
production and black markets. Not to mention,
it also led to a rise in gang violence and
organized crime. Congress would eventually
repeal this law 13 years later but we don’t even
have to look that far. We can just look at AdBlock
itself. The fact that there are multiple AdBlocks
on the Chrome webstore itself with hundreds of
millions of downloads each show that people will
work around rules that they don’t like. If AdBlock
is no longer the bypass for ads, they’ll find
a new bypass. Maybe that means downloading an
app that streams YouTube videos without ads
or downloading the videos through some sort
of third party application. YouTube may be
able to stop funny business from happening
directly on the platform but they can’t stop
it from happening just outside the platform.
This could easily lead to a situation in which
people still watch YouTube videos but just not
on YouTube itself. This is a massive problem for
YouTube because as Bill Gates said . Similarly, if
people are gonna watch YouTube videos without ads,
its in YouTube’s best interest that they still
watch it on YouTube itself. Sure, they may not
make money off of these viewers, but they still
have control and influence over these viewers
which could be monetized later down the road.
If people migrate over to some bootlegged version
of YouTube though, that’s no longer the case.
But, it’s not just these viewers that YouTube
risks losing. YouTube also risks losing the casual
viewer. The casual viewer probably isn’t gonna go
out of there way to pirate YouTube videos. But,
if they’re starting to feel that watching ads is
annoying, they’ll likely just watch YouTube less.
And in an era where attention is the most
valuable currency, YouTube is actively
trading long term attention and even addiction
for short term cash. Simply not a great trade.
Also, this trade may open up YouTube to
competition. For the longest time, YouTube
was impossible to compete against because it was
universally accessible and completely free. But,
as Google cracks down on ads, competitors now
have to ability to say “Come to our platform,
we don’t have ads.” This is exactly what Netflix
did with cable TV. Before viewers didn’t care
about such temptations because well they could
get the same experience on YouTube itself.
But, as Google cracks down, such alternatives
may seem more and more enticing. So,
if YouTube wants to protect their monopoly,
well then, allowing AdBlock is ironically
their best move. If people are gonna
steal, you want them to steal from you.
THE SOLUTION:
Ok all of this makes sense from a theoretical
standpoint. A lot of people use AdBlock so
clamping down so hard will no doubt piss off
a bunch of people and threaten the monopoly.
But then what is the alternative? How do you go
about monetizing viewers who don’t want to pay for
YouTube Premium and use AdBlock? Well, the answer
is simply what Google was already doing. Google
had it right the first time. You may not know this
but Google actually has their own AdBlock that’s
built into Chrome and is automatically enabled.
This likely seems super counterintuitive for an
ad company but this is the way. For any sort of
sales effort, the number one priority is to get
eyeballs. Only after that can you sell or monetize
or whatever. Google understood this perfectly.
Their number one priority was to get people to use
Chrome. They didn’t want ads to be the reason that
someone chose Safari or Edge over Chrome. And that
strategy worked out perfectly. Basically everyone
started using Chrome, and once everyone was on
the platform, Google focused on monetization. But,
with this new AdBlock crackdown on YouTube, it
seems like Google may have their priorities mixed
up. Now, you may be asking, if Google never cracks
down, how will they ever be able to monetize?
Well, for that, we can just look at Google search
once again. There’s plenty of ad blocks for Google
search ads as well. But Google didn’t ban these
or take them off the chrome webstore. Instead,
they straight up just partnered with them.
That’s right, Google pays Adblocking services to
whitelist Google specific ads. This is why most ad
blockers do not work with Google search ads. These
adblockers are literally getting paid to show
them but they wont just show any ad. They only
show ads that they feel are discrete and don’t
take away from the user experience because their
reputation is on the line. If the ads are too
annoying, people will simply blame the ad block
not Google and that’s the genius of this strategy.
For a small fee, Google is able to run their ads
without being the bad guy, and if people do get
annoyed, its the adblocker that takes the heat.
I think Google should have taken the same approach
on YouTube. Now, you might be saying that this is
misleading and it is but that’s not the goal. The
goal is not to trick people. The goal is to make
the ad experience so good that it’s not actually
a negative. Ideally, people shouldn’t even notice
that the AdBlock isn’t working. As such, the right
strategy isn’t to force people to watch ads by
banning AdBlock. The right strategy is to make the
ad experience so pleasant that people don’t even
feel the need to use AdBlock in the first place.
Google understood this perfectly for the longest
time and they still definitely do. Though with the
recent crackdown, it looks like they’re willing to
take a gamble. They’re essentially betting that
people are so addicted to YouTube that they can
force ads and get away with it. And they might be
able to with this move specifically, but that’s
a slippery slope. If they can force us to watch
ads, why not make it 2,3,4,5 ads? And before you
know it, YouTube will be indistinguishable from
cable TV. Is that where YouTube’s heading? Only
time will tell but this is not a great first
step and that’s why YouTube should feel stupid
for blocking adblock. Google is clearly losing
their cool but someone who isn’t is Microsoft.
If you’d like to learn about how Microsoft
gave up their ego, check out this next video.